good morning the shadow Home Secretary
Yvette Cooper is with me now are they
breaking the law or not
well I think there's lots of people
looking at the actual legislation at the
moment it was only published yesterday I
think the key thing is what impact
they're going to have on this serious
problem that we've got which is
dangerous Boat Crossings that have
really escalated shot up in the last
four years we need action to prevent
those Boat Crossings because it's
putting lives at risk and is also ending
up undermining our border security so
we've put forward proposals which we
believe will make a huge difference and
we would like to work with the
government on them My worry is that what
they put forward yesterday actually
risks making the problem worse it's
similar to some of the things that they
tried last year and as we saw the
problem just got worse numbers were
worse when you guys are in charge no
actually they weren't so there were
issues in the Bosnian crisis the
secretary told us that the numbers were
worse at Jack straw so the numbers were
worse when you guys were interested the
numbers of work we had the issue about
the Bosnian crisis so we did have the
issues I think in the early 2000s and
then the labor government at that time
took action to deal with those problems
and rightly so as well because I think
what everyone wants to see is proper
border security and also a property
managed and controlled system so the UK
does its bit alongside other countries
to support those who fled persecution
and conflict at the moment we don't have
either of those so we haven't got a
managed and controlled system it is
chaotic and we also don't have border
security in place because the criminal
gangs are operating with impunity we
have to go after those gangs and we
would set up new cross-border police
unit in order to do so because you've
had some reports important reports here
on Sky about people Smugglers who you
know journalists are able to find well
why aren't the police because we need
action against those gangs three
quarters of them are in the UK I was
shocked to see that report because that
just shows really the scale of the the
problem in the UK otherwise we've had
often government trying to suggest well
part of the reason they can't address
the problem is because the networks are
in France or in other countries well
what that shows is we really need this
cross-border police unit to go after the
gangs here to go after the Smugglers who
are here and also to work with the
French authorities Belgian authorities
and so on to go after the gang networks
really that are operating this this
dangerous trade in people
um the British people half of them want
um
migrants who are coming by this fashion
to be sent straight back home again the
government is basically just doing what
the people want well except that they're
not because they don't have any return
agreements in place so they're saying
that they're doing it well yeah I know
but they're making it harder to get the
return agreements and they're not
getting those in place because of the
way they're doing this in a sort of
chaotic unilateral way so we think you
should get return agreements in place
with Europe as part of a wider agreement
with particularly with France and
Belgium and other countries would need
to include managed alternative things
for example for for people who've got
family who've got relatives in the UK
but it's got to include those return
agreements with France that I think is
crucial to doing this if they did that
would labor then support what the
government is suggesting
well I think if you did that then you
wouldn't need many of the the things
that the government's talked about
because that actually would be at the
heart of it so there are some things for
example they're saying they need
legislation for that they can actually
do straight away so returning people to
Albania who've come from safe countries
they should be fast tracking those cases
and doing that now rather than waiting
for however long it's going to take to
get legislation through for whatever
their new processes are get on with that
now they could do that straight away
under the existing system and they're
not only one percent of last year's
cases from Albania through small boats
have actually been dealt with and
processed that is just nonsense but
they're doubling the number of home
office Personnel who deal with those
sort of applications in order to try to
hurry that up yeah and that's the right
thing to do so we support that but
they're not fast tracking safe country
cases I don't know why they're not but
they're currently just refusing to do
that and that's the obvious logical
thing to do if you want to maintain
confidence in the system you also want
to clear the backlog and not have huge
numbers of people in inappropriate
costly hotels which is just no good for
anyone so are they trying to address
that as well aren't they by opening up
these military camps um in order to hold
people there
and again yeah we we've not seen any
sign of those yet there's been lots of
twoing and throwing they've talked about
that for a long time but what it looks
like is because people will still arrive
under their new proposals they won't
take any Asylum decisions on them but
they don't have anywhere to return them
to so actually the risk is you're going
to have tens of thousands of additional
people just in the Asylum system just in
the still a sign of accommodation and in
hotels
yeah I know that's what they said entry
denied I know I know that's what he says
but because he's got no return
agreements in place because he's not
done that hard work with France and
other countries actually that's not
going to happen and all that will happen
is at the end of 28 days we've looked at
the legislation this is what it seems to
say at the end of 28 days they'll just
go back into an asylum hotel or Asylum
accommodation I wonder with no well you
know the I mean at the moment they're
saying that will be two to three hundred
people and you know whenever
that's to start with they can expand
that yeah the Rwanda has said they would
only take two to three hundred people so
45 thousand people came last year so
it's a tiny proportion and it's hugely
expensive as well I think you know the
Home Secretary herself I think admitted
it was failing and the home office
officials have said it's unenforceable
and very costly and at high risk of
fraud but why shouldn't economic
migrants be sent from whence they came
well I think they should I mean if
people
of Albania they should be sent back they
should be returned to Albania because
they've not fled persecution and
conflict I mean that's that's what a
fair system does but at the moment
they're not being because the
government's not making the existing
system work and that look in the end is
my worry about all of this that all they
do is they go for government by gimmick
they set out another set of headlines
another set of you know another set of
new laws and we had almost exactly the
same law you know nine months ago hasn't
worked but they're not actually tackling
the problem and then they just make
things worse by doing so we really need
them to get a grip I hope that Rishi
sunak does get a better agreement with
France this weekend so I hope they will
do that and we would work with them on
that but we need to work on the
Practical things that will solve this so
we can have those two things we want
border security and a properly
controlled and managed Refugee and
Asylum system when did you know that
sugray was speaking to the boss
um I didn't I'm afraid I've not been in
any of those discussions so I do not
find that surprising that um a job that
is probably one of the most important
jobs come government and the head of
your boss was not talking to people like
you in the Inner Circle to be honest I
think those are decisions for the leader
this is about you know his chief of
staff it's about his office so actually
I know I completely respect I think
that's rightly those are decisions for
care not ones that he wants half the
shadow cabinet frankly involved in
what about the other half or the whole
of the show there we go
very much indeed thank you